welcome to this video playing playing
dabra dabra we are okay Romania is what
day via or something no and Dora or
sorry about that but the same colors
isn't it okay if not it's closed so the
Rubenstein yeah 92 okay go with rookie
aid I play rook e8 and see six-year
always like this maneuver here with
Bishop afraid and very very elegant way
to play and tnite f form yeah white can
play that but it runs right into the c5
if i push after which it's not so clear
where the night really is headed okay
there okay
okay playing a 5 c6 those kind of things
should be quite okay for black nothing
nothing great but also not to worry
about yeah night takes is actually the
you know the the better move but night
night to see 5 might be might be
something here I have some ideas to to
play against his weakened queenside
Queen g6 Bishop f5 Bishop see to those
kind of things I am he's pushing it
immediately yeah I can I don't know i
can take here or i can also ignore it
okay night a six he also has c5 that's
probably not that great say okay let's
trade this let's trade this no night a
6b five I go back to see 5 which is
really nothing special but at least I'd
I should be okay here oh he's walking
right into this move before it's not a
move that wide wants to play that much
is clear let's drop back this is
debatable yeah hmm I should have gone
back to c8 right form night is 64 96
take here night checks protector should
be three maybe maybe I can prepare that
cb5 so it's a bit it's not very subtle
but
all right but it is enough pawn takes
Bishop b3 is embarrassing but he's
running right into it okay 95 yeah but
ok e4 hangs so rook d2 I would like
maybe here in fact let's think about it
for just a moment I would like to
activate my Bishop to c5 or something
like that maybe this for night F 495
night f4 made on g2 he's forced to take
now I believe then bishop what okay how
can he can play that but like really I
had only now saw idea that this is this
is coming the opinion yeah I made I made
a mistake here once he be sure instead
of Bishop e6 I should go all the way
back for for this what to g6 but I
should faciliate this 90 64 idea very
quickly and T I'm comfortable with
nothing special ok this is really
relying on this little trap but he he
simply ignored it takes a he has to take
with the night to give away here for ya
95 I can't even take I didn't even see
that I only saw that e4 hangs but ok
here yeah I could have taken this
ah yeah yeah yeah I only saw every only
saw it later only here okay you must
take and well this is this is going to
be rather comfortable win the Bishop to
c5 is very strong a group d to ideas the
right moment yeah should win okay thanks
for watching